on April seventeenth 2012 film courage
attended the roundtable press interview
for the meg and lawrence kasdan film
darling companion this audio contains an
interview with writers and director meg
and lawrence kasdan for more information
on darling companion please visit sony
classics calm forward slash darling
companion just guessing the hollywood
just want to finance anything about real
people that know superheroes may go we
did not take it to the studio to we did
not realize yeah i mean we didn't think
that it could survive that mmm it was
not susceptible to having notes about
you know the toilet should explode in
the middle of the movie so a day yeah
they don't make movies like this and
maybe they're smart maybe not but we
wanted to make this move and you some
help this amazing cast event it's worth
the scary we're credible I mean as
people would do anything to work with
you so when you surprise but like I
think that's very flattering I don't
know if it's true I think that they like
this script and they liked the other
people that were involved they were
excited by each other and we had Keaton
and Klein and it would caught up dan
wees to it worship for 30 years and she
loved the part and she wanted to be
there and she liked the idea of Jenkins
playing the other part Jenkins had
worked with me 25 years ago and
silverado and it's a mutual thing you
know and I we were made so we got
everybody we want Lizzie my side put her
in a movie when she's 16 years old so it
was really great did you find the
process of working on in front of a more
limited or more liberating it's about
your resources are limited your time is
limited you have to move like crazy but
there's never enough time to make
I've had a hundred days to see the movie
this week didn't 32 so you always use as
much time as you've got the work
experience of time a lot of it
absolutely but there's something
liberating about it in that nobody has a
trailer is everybody there for the
project no one's doing it for the money
because there is no money and the spirit
is extraordinary it was a real group
experience and everyone is game and the
actors have to be very cooperative which
they are the greatest actress in America
and you let him know at the beginning
you know we're only going to do a few
takes and I always said you know do you
want one more we could always do one
more and that was enough for people
sometimes they said sometimes I'd say
not on them they're incredibly
professional all these actors and when
we were casting the sheriff Lisa Duke we
do this and casting director said how
about Sam Sheppard music Sam Sheppard we
can't get Sam Sheppard to do this movie
for no money we come in for two weeks he
jumped in a car and Kentucky with his
dog and drove to you Tom stayed in a
crappy motel room he wouldn't even go in
regular is just a mas
because i have been in there a hotel but
it was better with his dog in this motel
and he just like sitting that he said I
think it's really funny I want to play
this part when you talk to you Joe 20
but an actor and it is Mark's was not
one of many rescues that you dr. W we
had another rescue done we adopted right
when when a long time ago our kids were
young we someone was giving a dog away
in front of gelsons and i took this took
him home i am for about like 11 years
and then this dog we we could breed I
saw an email about him I was sort of
hooked into this whole rescued network
through a friend of mine and saw his
picture and he just looks so sad look
like dog in jail he was in a shelter
finish on it but he only had a couple of
days left they were going to put him
down and we went we drove down to the
shelter and we looked at her we
considered it we had to go to a wedding
that night so we had they told us we had
to put a hold on him so nothing would
happen to him even in the one day we
went down the next day and took him up
all the money loans are in the movie you
used at the time was not was missing a
lot a lot i was shocked that um how
devastated I was when he disappeared
that when we thought we had lost him I
think it had to do with having rescued
him and we had them for two years after
we rescued him before this happened and
I think that when we rescued him and we
made a commitment we had a very rough
life we could tell that he was sort of
beat up when you're gone and we thought
you know we're going to make the rest of
his life good and we thought we had done
that and then all of a sudden he was
gone and it was
terrible terrain it's high in the Rocky
Mountains and the weather was awful you
know we thought he was soft could have
been suffering and naturalistic and that
was really hard to do you know what if
he'd fallen off something there's a lot
of cliffs and things there's wild
animals there's all the scary things
that could happen out there so we felt
terrible and I was actually taken aback
by how much I realized I care and we
started looking we did everything we
could think of it there was a point of
which we got skirts and as in the movie
there was a woman even knew the Dhavan
suit meg told her that the dog was
missing finally she was hesitant to tell
her and she said he's all right I had
never told you this but I find things
and he's under I know he's still alive
he's out there and I said how do you
know that she said well I have this
special affinity for animals and I have
already started thinking about this and
I'm positive lead out there and you just
have to go and look for him again we
have been going back and forth from LA
to Colorado looking for so we went back
another time and she was right about
these directions on the phone you know
go to the ice cream store and look
around there since we have melt no
reason about anywhere else anyway we
were just looking or never you don't
know what it's hard to look for
something like that you know what it
could be anyone so you're sort of
walking down trails and walking down
roads just calling calling you so when
she gave us a place of course you could
go because it's like why not as good as
anywhere else to look for him I was it
perfect the title for them no but what
did I think what's the great gift that
she did was she just kept us at and we
never let up and I think that was her
she said you the only way you're going
to lose his dog is when you stop looking
when you give up hope that you'll find
him then he's lost until that moment is
endless
just like the couple in the fell me to
have been long time Mary what's the
secret to his success well we've been
married for 40 years we've raised two
sons we have a grandchild we've done a
lot of things together over those years
I think we can make each other laugh
we've been patient with each other we
sort of had an ongoing conversation over
those 40 years about one thing or
another and then it's just walk you know
just luck and it's just sort of sticking
with it everybody has their hard times
and if do you stick with it or do you
not all of them yeah and we just have
you know we can't guess we're
codependent or something that's another
great thanks get 11 schools get out of
work with a lot of people ask us about
it and they say how can you work with
your wife and don't you get sick of
seeing or out of down and out of you you
did but it's been very pleasant we we
wrote together for the first time I'm
Grand Canyon but we've been working
together really before that make it was
a music coordinator and Big Chill and so
it's been many many years of her being
people involved and the thing and then
it became explicitly and started running
here they do you think it's the
experience of your own long and healthy
Marge that led you to cast the male and
female lead of a couple that are
actually the same age as each other as
opposed to me mysticum amusing the
husband's with the wide 20 years younger
and that was also one of the plants
refreshing things about the film oh good
the thing is that they're very few
movies nowadays where the protagonists
are out this age and that's a shame and
it's not surprising given what Hollywood
is making then you figured it not going
to be room for 60 year old protagonists
in those movies but even and independent
from there aren't that many that are
based around 60 year olds and it's but
in fact the audience is that
in that's much more from for dion is the
growing segment of that it's not the
younger and there's a very loyal and
they like to go to the theater to it not
just they want to watch it on TV or dvd
r they actually like the theater-going
experience the problem is that every
friday afternoon they open up the paper
and there's not a lot of choices for
them so it's too bad that they're not
being served and you know this movie
will hopefully serve them but it's very
hard to get them to theatre the studio
this is a good studio distributing this
but um they don't spend a lot of money
so we've been going around like Willy
Loman transalta thing all of the country
and hoping that we can you know nurtured
along what what did you select Mark
Douglas I'm just gonna you know we when
we came to the heart it was right at the
beginning of casting and an aging we
knew suggested another actor and we met
him and he was very hot off of TV show
and I didn't like him I just talking to
media to this and the neck and the next
day she said dad what about Mark Duplass
and I said I've seen him your potty
chair and I've seen his movies and if I
would never have thought of him because
he doesn't make regular again I movies
that much and I said sure we'll meaning
they said he had read the script and
they really want to play this part so he
came I mean men I thought it would be
the first of 20 guys that we would meet
but we never met anybody else we he was
something so intriguing about him his
whole quality is you haven't seen it a
lot he's great with Jenkins and we
thought he was believable I was a young
doctor yeah he has that quality and we
didn't meet anybody else football team
captures field first screenplay yeah
transfer to get my how did you feel when
with you don't I'll terrible error story
is unbelievably tragic and the details
become worse and worse as time goes on
it when I knew it and I didn't know her
well I would produce that movie I didn't
directors I wrote produced it but um she
was very sweet she was already a
gigantic singing star but she there was
no diva in her there was no entourage
that she was very vulnerable about
acting she never acted before Kevin to
his credit was very good with her is
very supportive of her and helped her
along with that part and my experience
of her was all good and everything
horrible that hallowed was not evident
at that time is 1991 they were making
that we were making that movie and you
could not have guessed they'd go so
horribly wrong you can play how many
people in the industry that we
interviewed that have children that side
oh I hope I can stomp follow me into the
business and both your kids are ya did
you have any calls about them you know
they just were doing it from a pretty
young age and we certainly didn't
discourage them we didn't encourage them
either but they both by the time they
were finished with high school it was
clear they were doing this and so we
just thought we should be we realized
what when they were in high school the
big could both right which is kind of
amazing that they just put and we felt
pretty confident about that that they
could make a living writing and whether
they would get the chance to director
not hard to say and it's just you know
with our job is to encourage them and
support them and be happy when you
things go well they both dropped out of
college after one year big
disappointment to us he'll tell them I
think
yeah they're not resisted one the
everyone went to New York Tisch School
you know the film school and the other
one had gone to Hampshire which is very
liberal arts and plays in Massachusetts
but I'm UC Santa and UC Santa Cruz he
changed but they both were writing I
read ian and they dropped out and one
came to work on one of my movies and
never went back and he started he
directed his own movie at 22 still his
that day and then the younger one
after year dish dropped out and
immediately got a job writing television
so it's hard to complain and that we
never even really supported them they
sort of cut loose you must be very proud
very bad when they're good kids and that
was the main thing and we're very close
you know sir and they're the first
people that read her stuff and we read
theirs and what's the special
relationship with Captain um I met him
you know casting body heat and I didn't
use them but I thought I gotta work with
this guy and when I next did Big Chill I
thought he's got to be in this group he
can do anything he's an athlete he was a
great writer it's over other handled the
guns really well if you've ever seen him
on stage you know that it's an athlete
and he's one of the funniest people on
earth and pure pleasure to work with a
great dramatic actor when I see him in
the morning I'm have to be there and to
really benefit when you're making movies
to arrive and see people you like what's
such a long resume what keeps you going
um you know when you get to be 63 it
won't seem like next week i shall
guarantee you'll find that you feel very
much as you did when you were 30
37 40 and you can't the question of why
I keep feeling never comes up it never
occurs to you should be fun it's still
fun you think I'm very much in the
middle of my life and any one of us
could drop dead tomorrow so the question
is yeah I hate to tell you that Bob
street that's what will fit my field so
it never creates you like oh I should
you know give it up what occurs to you
is is there a place in movies can i
still get movies minute because
Hollywood I don't think i can get movies
wait i don't think there's anything i
hope i'm wrong but it's so few movies
they're making that I want to see to a
doubt that I'm the guy that's going to
direct but I do believe this plenty of
movies being made that I like and so
there has to be a way to get them a
quick question but it is good wanted to
stay on this movie but when you were
putting together the music for the big
chill did you know that it was going to
be like I mean if there's like maybe
three other soundtracks in history that
has become that I know we had never it
was a it was the most fun to put that
soundtrack together i'm larry said you
know find a bunch of songs that from our
time really in from the 60s that we hope
that we liked when we were in college
and make a big you know put together a
big collection of those songs and we'll
pick some of them and we'll put him in
the movie and and if you have n he said
you know if i had any ideas about where
in the movie they would go I told him so
that was just an incredibly pleasant
thing to do I had two small children at
the time so I could listen to music and
make these tapes these old tapes that we
still have someone and then every once
in a while I'd get an idea about where
something should be used some in
some of those songs we had hoped I
written into the script I can't always
get can always get what you want that's
in the script and we just really um
heard it through the grapevine mega-hit
that that about the opening sequence we
knew we wanted to get that I'm from
Detroit so I grew up with real Motown
Berry Gordy definitely I love that music
in Michigan we had they were back to
what we want to when we heard all the
British songs British use it to but we
blow the motel that's almost a musical I
mean I mean get the movie know in a
weird way yeah yeah anyway I just
wondering is that really like talking by
your favorite sent you home fragrance
movie should be yeah right now this is
jeff it's a rescue dog